oh he knows it  wow  wow he knows it  he knows it's just  russian school he knows it but he  couldn't prevent it as  just terrorist so he's going okay for  and now it's very simple for for daniel  do both just sit and  wait  just no way you can improve here  yeah and that's tough so  we see danny duboff and izzy panko it  will be a draw we see  uh completely  devastated he would just take on h6 and  it would be like h6 check and he would  take  no i don't think so you will try no i  won't try  he's devastated he's just suffering here  he doesn't believe  he took on h6 as i told you that's why  uh someone there is a fish  a smoker cannot read anyone  um  yeah and ez panko is just disgusted with  his performance  okay the match is not over so you should  be careful  not showing too many weak sign of  weaknesses because  this will give extra boost to daniel who  doesn't need it  okay and we have the last game going on  between sam shankland  and grenade jumabayev  win